[Musique]
qu'est ce qui distingue les simples
informations des informations de
renseignement
ce qu'on appelle en anglais intelligence
j'ai demandé à sergueï narychkine
directeur du service de renseignement
extérieur de la fédération de russie de
m'aider à y voir plus clair sergueï est
bénéfique merci de nous avoir accordé du
temps
commençons par le sujet international le
plus brûlant le retrait des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan dans l'espace
médiatique russe de nombreuses
évaluations idéologiques politiques et
stratégiques ont déjà été faites je
voudrais tout d'abord vous demandez
comment cela affectera les méthodes et
les priorités de vos services dans cette
région dont une pièce difficile aux
caselles store
sa boutique b'inside et bien je dois
tout d'abord dire que les événements en
afghanistan si rouste ou toujours été au
centre de l'attention du service de
renseignement extérieur
en raison de la position stratégique de
ce pays
et de la menace terroriste potentielle
et réelle qui a toujours émané du
territoire afghan
et aux tomates aux
postes-clés
le fait est qu'après à l'entrée des
troupes américaines et des forces
alliées sur le territoire de ce pays
l'opinion a prévalu dans la communauté
mondiale que grâce aux américains
la situation reviendrait à la normale et
que la présence des troupes américaines
et de l'otan n'a constituait une
barrière fiable pour empêcher
l'extension de cette menace terroriste
sur tout l'espace eurasien ogre aux
na'vis d'hab ce livre-disque
malheureusement cela ne s'est pas avéré
être le cas et après le retrait des
troupes après la fuite des américains
d'afghanistan brrr ce bien ils ont
laissé derrière eux une économie en
ruine économique où la montée des
groupes terroristes
[Musique]
l'aggravation des conflits ethniques
l'intensification du trafic de
stupéfiants et de la contrebande d'armes
au stadium of light
[Musique]
est
absolument pensez vous que ce sera
désormais plus facile d'y travailler ou
que ce sera plus difficile a été il ya
vous savez
j'ai dit tout cela pour souligner qu'il
y avait des facteurs encourageants
résidents tout d'abord dans le fait que
la normalisation de la situation en
afghanistan
la volonté de stabiliser la situation en
relève désormais de la compétence de
toutes les puissances régionales
et des pays d'asie centrale et la chine
de l'inde du pakistan de l'iran et bien
sûr de la russie à la scie et
cet égard l'interaction des services de
renseignement dans le cadre du
partenariat est également d'une grande
importance
et je dois dire qu'aujourd'hui nous
menons aussi un dialogue de partenariat
intense avec nos collègues
avec les services de renseignements de
presque tous les pays que j'ai
mentionnés
vous savez il ya tout juste un mois et
demi j'ai eu l'occasion de parler avec
l'ancien président afghan hamid karzaï
et nous avons discuté avec lui de cette
vieille thèse de ce big dave brésil ce
qui selon laquelle l'afghanistan en tant
que centre de lure asie ou d état se
battent pour leur sphère d'influencé
acquiert une nouvelle importance
précisément parce que certains pays
comme par exemple la russie et la chine
ont pu trouver un équilibre entre leurs
intérêts et essayer de synchroniser
leurs efforts pour élaborer une solution
mutuellement acceptable
d'autres acteurs régionaux pour antilles
selon vous faire de même parce que la
chine et la russie c'est une chose nous
avons un partenariat stratégique
mais s'agissant par exemple de l'inde ou
du pakistan
ce sont des relations tout à fait
différente ou bien à l'iran la turquie
oui vous savez quand vous avez prononcé
le nom de ce digne f jezzine ski je me
suis souvenu d'une autre confession
qu'il avait fait dans l'une de ses
interviews dans les années 90 je crois
il disait que le jour de l'entrée des
troupes soviétiques en afghanistan
en tout cas il avait écrit au président
carter une note contenant ce genre de
mots
les etats unis une excellente occasion
de créer pour les soviétiques leur
propre vietnam
les années ont passé et à mon avis les
américains sont tombés dans ce piège
watteau watteau la gauche ensuite bien
sûr et le destin de l'afghanistan
est entre les mains des afghans eux
mêmes
en outre comme je lé déjà évoqué le
développement pacifique et durable de
l'afghanistan est dans l'intérêt de tous
les pays de la région si
sony
serait très intéressant d'entendre le
plus tôt possible
la voix des afghans eux-mêmes
non seulement celle des talibans
mais aussi celle des représentants
d'autres groupes ethniques groupe les
otakus et les pays de la région mène un
dialogue intense
et la plateforme la plus efficace et
dynamique femme est probablement celle
de l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai
récemment il y a quelques jours une
réunion conjointe des dirigeants des
pays membres de l'hôtesse et et de l'eau
cs a eu lieu à douchanbé
et bien sûr si toi tu la situation en
afghanistan était au centre de
l'attention
toutefois
il faudrait certainement impliqué
également nos participants occidentaux
dans ce dialogue
leur participation est à mon avis
approprié car elles doivent comprendre
que grâce à leur action l'afghanistan a
subi d'importantes pertes
et leurs responsabilités et de fournir
un volet financier pour le
rétablissement d'une vie normale en
afghanistan afin de rétablir la
stabilité et la sécurité dans ce pays
permettez moi de vous poser une autre
question concernant vos partenaires
occidentaux car aux états unis beaucoup
accusent en ce moment la cia de manque
de professionnalisme et d'incapacité à
prévoir correctement l'évolution des
événements on estimait que le
gouvernement afghan officielle devait
rester au pouvoir pendant au moins six
mois de votre point de vue de
professionnels ont-ils vraiment raté
quelque chose ou s'agit-il d'une
tentative de faire porter le chapeau à
vos collègues américains
en effet nos collègues de la cia se
trouve maintenant dans une situation un
peu enviable
plutôt dirais-je qu'il ne s'agit pas
seulement 2 à seulement de la cia
afghanistani it has pushed nouveau vous
le fait est que ce qui s'est passé en
afghanistan
ce retrait précipité des troupes et la
fuite du gouvernement fantoche
d'afghanistan et tout cela est la
conséquence de la politique pernicieuse
des états unis et de leur ligne pour
ainsi dire d'imposition de leur modèle
de développement social
soyez
voilà
et il ya beaucoup de monde à blâmer pour
cela beaucoup sont responsables de ces
fautes
ce ne sont pas seulement les agents de
la cia
c'est aussi le département de la défense
le service de renseignement militaire
le département d'état
c'est aussi le bureau du conseiller du
président à la sécurité nationale
mais je le répète la cia fait partie de
ce grand mécanisme est bien sûr à bien
des égards la faute leur incombe il ya
au but
mais en même temps je suis sûr que les
dirigeants américains possédaient des
informations complètes sur ce qui se
passait en afghanistan et sur la manière
dont les événements pouvaient évoluer
la seule chose qu'ils n'ont pas pris en
compte ce sont leurs propres capacités
ils n'ont pas voulu voir la vérité si
vous voulez
n'y serait-il
est là et étaient prêts à vous dire
glaser la vérité est que les états unis
ne pouvais plus remplir cette fonction
est d'hégémonie mondiale qu'ils se sont
attribués eux mêmes vous y attend ça me
met je signe mes fans sont à prévoir
guimond
puis-je vous poser une question à ce
sujet il me semble que la façon dont les
dirigeants politiques américains
détermine aujourd'hui leur politique
étrangère mérite qu'on y prête attention
parce que le président bailly donne a
déclaré ces dernières semaines que la
sécurité des états unis était leur
principale priorité l'emportant sur
l'expansion de la démocratie à
l'étranger on dirait que le texte de ce
discours sont rédigées par d'anciens
employés du bureau du président russe
car il ya beaucoup de points qui
semblent faire écho à la doctrine
sécurité russes selon laquelle notre
tâche principale est d'assurer la
sécurité du pays alain ailleurs du pays
selon vous est il serait intéressant de
savoir si vous pouvez faire des
pronostics est ce une déclaration
sérieuse ou est ce plutôt une sorte
d'exercice rhétorique peut-on s'attendre
à ce que la politique américaine
deviennent disons moins
interventionniste un moyen terme
eh bien je dirais que de telles
déclarations du président américain les
chefs de l'administration américaine
sont avant tout bien sûr une réaction et
une réponse à cette fuite honteuse
d'afghanistan a vogué houston et les
mots eux-mêmes ont aussi leur propre
sens
mais d'après tous les maux surtout s'ils
sont répétés à plusieurs reprises
prépare dans une certaine mesure le
public
oui certainement est légitime certains
principes et le locuteur lui-même et
dans une certaine mesure la réalité elle
même
donc le temps nous le dira
mais en même temps nous savons que les
paroles des dirigeants américains
ne s'accorde pas souvent avec leurs
actes
les nous voyons déjà la formation pour
ainsi dire de nouveau plan offensif
s'échappe et al
thani regardez les états unis tentent de
maintenir leur influence et leur
contrôle sur cet espace en renforçant
leurs positions dans les pays d'asie
centrale
c'est la première chose
messier mans il ya les événements très
récent il ya la formation d'une nouvelle
alliance militaro technologique entre
les états unis le royaume uni et
l'australie abstral et bien qu est-ce
que cela donc le temps nous le dira nous
devons être très vigilants
toutefois vous avez dit à plusieurs
reprises que moscou considérait la cia
comme un service partenaire
dingue les partenaires des noms aux
partenaires comment déterminez vous
personnellement le degré de confiance
raisonnable d'entr'aide et de prudence
à la pitié
généraux des sites wap l'évolution de la
situation internationale
à l'étape actuelle engendre de nombreux
nouveaux risques jusque là inconnu
innove tahiti et dans de telles
conditions bien sûr la coopération des
services spéciaux et des services de
renseignement est importante par
conséquent nous entretenons de nombreux
partenariats avec presque tous les
services de renseignement du monde y
compris avec la cia qui savent fier mais
bien sûr je voudrais d'abord dire que la
nature
la profondeur et le contenu de nos
relations de partenariat avec la cia et
le fbi
ne sont pas du tout les mêmes que nos
relations et notre coopération avec les
services de renseignement des pays
faisant partie de l'hôtesse et humaniste
de la sévit
avec la chine
l'inde
je le répète leur profondeur et leur
caractère sont bien sûr différent
pouvez-vous faire confiance à des
informations fournies par un état qui
déclare ouvertement voir notre pays
comme un ennemi comme une force
subversive
c'est exactement ce que dit le dernier
rapport du renseignement américain sur
les menaces
ou d'une façon secondaire la menace
terroriste est considéré comme moindre
par rapport à 10 ans la menace que
représenterait la russie
lé 10 am entreprises je tiens à répéter
que nous apprécions vraiment notre
coopération avec nos collègues de la cia
dans le domaine de la lutte contre le
terrorisme international
il s'agit d'une menace réelle et les
résultats d'une telle coopération sont
utiles pour notre pays comme pour les
états unis ces unions marche un
famélique et
il me semble ou au moins je veux croire
que l'évolution de la situation dans le
monde en particulier les récents
événements en afghanistan et au delà
nageur américain donne à nos partenaires
américains le terrain pour repenser leur
classement des menaces michy souvenirs
rythme bros il y a eu tant de raisons
pour le faire mais ils sont
malheureusement jamais parvenu ah oui
et j'espère qu'ils comprendront que la
menace terroriste
du 6 au 11 est devenue une véritable
menace planétaire
i mais que nous reviendrons enfin à une
interaction constructive moi le mot
connaît mutuellement bénéfique fahim
horrible avec nos partenaires américains
sergueïevitch permettez moi de faire une
courte pause le seront de retour dans
quelques instants rester avec nous
[Musique]
avant la pause nous avons parlé de
l'ensemble des menaces existantes je
voudrais vous poser une question qui
pourrait sembler un peu lyrique ou
éthique puisque dans vos interviews vous
parlez souvent de questions de moralité
et d'immoralité j'aimerais savoir dans
quelle mesure on suit un code d'honneur
dans les milieux du renseignement et du
contre espionnage qui de manière
générale ne se distingue pas par une
sentimentalité excessive me semble-t-il
à moins que les intérêts de la patrie
justifie tout
est bien pour le service de
renseignement étranger la thèse selon
laquelle la fin justifie les moyens
n'est pas en absolu fausto les mouches
petit plus donc encore une news est pour
moi non plus
note
je vais donner un exemple historique
dans la seconde moitié des années 30
rastani lorsqu on pouvait déjà ressentir
une grande guerre approchait et que les
puissances militaires de l'allemagne
d'hitler augmentait dirigeants
politiques du pays avait besoin
d'information
alors un certain général de la wehrmacht
a été choisi comme source potentielle
ils étaient informés et francy dire très
affectueux envers les représentants du
sexe féminin
ce qu'on appelle un ronnie trap
est donc un plomb a été élaboré et la
tâche a été confiée un agent très
expérimenté qui était en même temps une
très belle femme il s'agit de zaouïah
rivkin à crescent callas après avoir
pris connaissance du plan elle a dit
bien sûr j'accomplirai la tâche je
livrerai l'information mais après cela
je me tirerais une balle dans la tête le
sujet était clos naturellement le plan a
été modifié les informations ont été
obtenues par le service de renseignement
extérieur soviétique
et fournit aux dirigeants du pays
les alliés arabes qui n'a a poursuivi
son travail pour le bien de la patrie et
de nos jours elle est considérée comme
un agent de renseignement soviétiques
légendaire
pour parler de nouvelles technologies je
suis sûr que vous savez que dans la
presse occidentale
le service de renseignement extérieur
est souvent associé au groupe de
'hackers' cosy beurre et vous avez
maintes fois nié publiquement
l'existence de ces liens mais il me
semble qu'avec le niveau actuel de
développement cyber technologique il est
clair que tout état qui se respecte est
obligé d'avoir des cyber force à la fois
défensives et offensives
pensez vous qu'il arrivera un jour où la
communauté internationale déclarera que
ces forces existent et parlera de leurs
capacités et imposera peut-être même des
restrictions sur leur utilisation comme
c'est le cas par exemple avec les forces
nucléaires
concernant les cyber attaques attribuées
à notre service qui contre la société
solar wind ces déclarations sont pour
ainsi dire sans fondement
il y avoir de matériaux pauvres a dit
mais je sois biaussat soir lors d'une
interview monte à vladimir soloviev je
crois j'ai fait référence aux documents
publics les audiences qui ont eu lieu si
je ne me trompe pas plus tôt cette année
à deux comités spéciaux du congrès
américain vu de chez la commission sur
le renseignement et le département de la
sécurité intérieure
où lé leader américain dans le domaine
de la cybersécurité
et de la cyber agression microsoft
crown strike mais les failles
ont déclaré après avoir mené une enquête
sur cet incident qui a duré plusieurs
jours même plusieurs mois
qu'il n'avait aucune preuve pointant
vers un état quelconque nacac au liban
certainement mais vous êtes d'accord
qu'il serait irresponsable de notre part
de ne pas montrer d'intérêt pour ce
domaine d'activité stratégiquement
importants n'ont cogné muslim
nous suivons pour ainsi dire le
développement de ce domaine parce que
nous ne devons pas être à la traîne
devons simplement être en mesure
d'assurer la sécurité de notre pays dans
ce domaine
[Musique]
vous savez que l'état russe qui
s'efforce de créer sur diverses
plateformes internationales un système
de sécurité internationales
de sécurité internationale de
l'information et bien sûr nous voyons
également les actions de nos partenaires
qui développent leurs cyber potentiel
offensif à la fois aux états unis et
dans les pays de l'otan
mais je peux vous assurer c'est ainsi
que nos auditeurs et nos téléspectateurs
que la russie garantir à sa sécurité
dans ce domaine
je voudrais évoquer un autre sujet avec
lequel les services de renseignement
russes sont souvent associés dans les
médias occidentaux
c'est ce qu'on appelle le syndrome de la
1 qui comprend des maux de tête des
troubles de l'équilibré de louis et même
des lésions cérébrales à long terme qui
seraient diagnostiqués chez des
militaires et des diplomates américains
à l'étranger
à votre avis une telle arme et l
techniquement possible et vos agents
août il fait face à des phénomènes et
des symptômes similaires à des
affections de ce genre
j'ai commencé mon travail dans le
renseignement extérieur soviétique au
département du renseignement
scientifique et technique
pour cette raison je m'intéressais aux
différentes direction que prenait la
recherche scientifique et je sais qu'en
occident à cette époque où le net déjà
des recherches assez intense
il y avait des études sur l'impact de
diverses ondes électromagnétiques des
oscillations sur le cerveau humain y
compris pour évaluer les possibilités de
contrôler le comportement humain en tout
cas ça tu sois là
quant à votre question de savoir si nous
avons eu des cas
si des agents du service de
renseignement extérieur de la russie ont
subi de tels symptômes quelque part dans
le monde dit i love coco la réponse est
non
très intéressant pour continuer sur le
thème du progrès scientifique
j'aimerais vous poser une question sur
votre évaluation d'origine du virus à
roscoff 2 vous avez déclaré plus d'une
fois que vous partiez du fait qu'il
était d'origine naturelle mais cependant
parmi vos collègues il y a de plus en
plus de sceptiques face à cette question
en particulier chez vos collègues
occidentaux
ce tube est selon vous qu'est ce qui
suscite cette incertitude
votre position sur l'origine de ce virus
n'a telle pas changé au cours des
derniers mois il me semble pourtant bien
montré une trajectoire de développement
très atypique pour un virus
l'humanité n'a probablement jamais connu
quelque chose de semblable et si nous
regardons les pertes humaines et les
pertes économiques
ce virus semble même plus effrayant que
n'importe quelle guerre car il ya
beaucoup de gens qui souffrent
je dois dire d'abord que la réponse
finale à cette question devra être
donnée par des scientifiques des
microbiologistes des géologues voilà est
sans aucun doute ils font des recherches
essaie de trouver une réponse définitive
à cette question
là aussi les agents du renseignement
pour aider non
[Musique]
vous savez il ya quelques temps la
communauté du renseignement des états
unis a publié un rapport à ce sujet
il contenait des estimations très vague
mais je dirais politiser ce qui est bien
sûr inhabituel pour le renseignement et
cela semble également très peu
professionnel pour le renseignement
vous donne mon avis cela est dû à la
crise provoquée par les efforts déployés
pour politiser les activités de la
communauté américaine du renseignement
voilà et c'est donc pourquoi nous nous
en tenons bien sûr quant à la version et
c'est la version adoptée par la plupart
de la communauté scientifique
je pense que ce virus
à une origine naturelle sergey nevic il
nous reste quelques minutes seulement je
vous en prie je voudrais également
abordés un domaine d'activité assez
inhabituel de votre service à savoir le
soi-disant renseignements historiques
je sais que vous avez des spécialistes
qui participent à la recherche et
l'étude de documents qu'ils obtiennent
des informations
des conclusions qui sont ensuite mis sur
la table du chef d'état pour prendre des
décisions
vous parlez probablement plutôt des
documents qui se trouve en grande partie
dans nos archives et nous travaillons
très attentivement avec ses archives
pour déclassifier certains documents qui
comme vous l'avez dit font effectivement
la lumière sur certains événements du
passé très près les whitecaps 15 minutes
et vous avez de tesla avons rendu public
un grand nombre de documents d'avant
guerre de la guerre et de l'après guerre
nimani
pédaler public nestier balshaw qualité
cette période
les années
30-40 bayonne et peut-être du début des
années 50 et la plus controversée pour
ainsi dire
les débats sur les causes le cours et
les résultats de la seconde guerre
mondiale se poursuivent toujours
et là nous est donc bien sûr nos
historiens histoire mettre en lumière ce
que nous considérons être la vérité soit
tout propos et les documents nous ont
beaucoup aidés
sergei kennedy je vous remercie de nous
accorder du temps bonne chance dans vos
activités professionnelles auxquelles
vous mène merci pour votre attention
vers le service de renseignement
extérieur de la russie
[Musique]